again planning extra travel time is
important thousands coming out of the
speedway headed on to the 15 coming from
edc we've got to live team coverage
hector mejia live near the speedway with
the latest good morning hector the i-15
is looking terrible how are things
looking where you are
well thankfully no problems right here
in this immediate area other than a
nonstop parade of vehicles here moving
over the last two hours we are seeing
traffic here but thankfully it's moving
along we don't see you know a big
traffic jam but this is what we're
seeing here right at this corner right
outside the speedway a lot of people
leaving the festival right now it
brought 150 000 people to the speedway
each of the last three days so we
checked in with the nevada department of
transportation they're recommending
everyone around the valley right now
specifically up here in the north part
of the valley to add a few extra minutes
to their morning drive as this major
festival is already done to help
alleviate some of that congestion and
dot lifted some lane reductions and
orange barrels that had put out for that
ongoing project at the i-15 and 215
interchange
we just want everybody to be safe
and make sure that they're aware when
they are driving and
and so i-15 south there's going to be
congestion and you have to pay attention
there might you know vehicles might stop
in front of you
quickly
so reminder to pay close attention as
roadwork continues on the 95 515 down
there ndot has crews in the middle of
that freeway working on that project so
with all these drivers headed in that
direction you'll run into more traffic
and out there in the distance back out
here live you can see that is the
traffic that's leaving the speedway and
trying to get onto the i-15 so you'll
run into all of these extra commuters on
the highway as you head out the door
this morning reporting live hector mejia
live local now